got another video right here of a giants
fan
reacting to the eagles stealing their
player
are you kidding me are you smoke get the
[ __ ] upstairs now
get the [ __ ] upstairs now
are you kidding me you [ __ ] put a
hole
and the guy punched two holes into the
wall the guy couldn't handle the pick
the draft picked the giants the eagles
stole the draft pick
and the guy put two holes into the wall
here's what i'm saying ladies you want
the holes in the wall
you want the holes in the wife
sometimes you got the exertion has to
get out
so i think that this man did the right
thing
i think his wife also did the right
thing by telling him
to get the [ __ ] out if suddenly he
thinks he's a damn general contractor
when he's hopped up on [ __ ] heineken
summer rail
at 4pm in the afternoon
to be a damn giants fan come on bro
y'all got evan ingram y'all should have
him throw and catch the ball dude
but look man that's the kind of stuff
that's going on out there in god's world
man and so that's what happens when you
watch the nfl draft
dude go to flag football watch flag
football
it's better some of it's co-ed there's
hot chicks bro
live it up hope you enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one
you